oh boy Angry Birds Angry Birds let's be
optimistic maybe Angry Birds the movie
is really good we have not seen this we
have not heard good things
games fun I like the game fine got a
little out of control I guess you can
tell there's a movie on it long after
the game at peak yeah this is how like
when the simpsons movie came out it's
just like dude you had your window but I
think it did well I'm not positive but a
lot of people have requested it and I
really didn't want to see it but when
it's very rare that we see a movie that
we want to see for the show so for our
crimes they gave us Angry Birds I swore
I was never gonna sit through this movie
I made a promise to God let's see what
rob breaking his promise to God looks
like this is Angry Birds we wrecked to
Spiderman franchises now let's try our
hands at video game movies sorry
accidentally put in Kung Fu Panda
he's clearly afraid he's not angry false
advertising just like the Smurfs movie
again where it's just movement its
movement porn a cow it has the same
dialogue as like half the script to
Rocky ow ow ow ow ow more blows landed
[Music]
I'll give it this I could not have
predicted this is the direction it would
go in the first five seconds
yes yeah I fell in the monks shouldn't a
squirrel be bigger that's your worry I
wasn't till I saw a bird but don't tell
me a story
just take responsibility hey man it
wasn't a story
everyone seems weirdly indifferent in
this universe you're late
Am I yeah goofy what the heck is gluten
I mean does gluten even exist
that's your first bake topper joke does
gluten exist in deep because
honestly at its base level I find
somebody getting hit in the face with a
kick kind of hilarious
I even crack a smile at that you messed
up literal splat stick it's a boy did
that go ridiculously dark every cast
member requested that their name be in
the corner
yeah I see them everybody's just tucked
away from center stage this is kind of
amazing good we've been watching this
now for a half hour and it's gotta be
only five minutes so apparently Doug's
notes just got deleted which i think is
a sign from God that we're not supposed
to watch the rest of the movie or I'm
just a dumb ass watching a dumb movie I
think it's both let's just intended to
scare children
this is scared straight for bad movies
it's gonna scare you into seeing better
films I'm just constantly
annoyed constantly right now it was
pretty instant mm-hmm yeah like it's
just the opening frame I'm just like do
not like it didn't have to warm us up to
it you know was tangled the last movie
we have the head of funny mime joke
anytime I see a mime in a movie it's
like seeing a mime in real life it's
just it's gonna suck you know this
should be very easy to animate and make
funny it's an angry bird who just cracks
and
Tagg how is not it's fun it's it's
slow-mo that's funny
cuz it's in slow-mo I hate to say it but
the emoji movie is more creative and
equally garbage but I just felt there
was slightly more thought put into that
about like what do we do with emojis
witty Terence seems to have
had an incident okay I kind of like that
if they never show what he did that'd be
amazing
remember that hilarious an anger
management level and Angry Birds so
exciting ironically every kid watching
this it's just playing Angry Birds wow
this is ah huh eagle heron peacock
warrior locust King pigeon we're like
15-20 minutes into this movie it's like
a an hour already losing my goddamn mind
it's charming up to a point and now it's
just sad where the double entendre is
talking about the movie is yeah every
line he has you could just say the
person who wrote this script were they
secretly trolling the project like are
they gonna milk a cow at some point and
be like well you can try to milk this
cow for all it's worth but judging by
its age I'd say it's five years too late
it's probably expired
okay whenever you milk out of it give it
to some five-year-old so drink anything
[Music]
mean to photobomb you sorry about that
Yanis bummed that joke smash it drop it
directly on top of the house which would
have been funnier god damn it Phil so
that's the running joke the huggy bird
doesn't get a hug don't go
how lucky got hurt I haven't seen that
yet I can't do this I am with you I
think this is far worse than the emoji
movie your emoji movie had some
creativity some you know visual resinous
I mean this is just constant gnawing and
annoyance I hate the emoji movie for
what it represents
this is worse although you can make the
argument this represent the exact same
thing it's a goddamn phone app move in
oh that's my toothbrush get it out
[Applause]
that's my toothbrush don't use it suck
those bellies in instead in stem did you
hear that
it's another pun that went well
if you're me dummy what a great line
dummy it's too much man so this was
written like in the bathroom right I
mean this just yeah definitely on a
phone 100% first hatch ding their script
the phone sitting on the
it kind of use your home what's that
what are you trying to say
abused your help oh I'm sorry I couldn't
quite hear you over your ego I need your
help
oh you have the first test you drank my
piss it's a good metaphor for the movie
here watches these birds piss on you and
you're just gonna drink it I'm a broken
human being inside sitting here watching
this I honestly am almost like you know
maybe I was a little harsh on door
Matadors it's so unfunny it's so so
crushingly unfunny there was like a
jaw-dropping aspect to norm of the north
it makes it a little more memorable like
I'm just like I can't believe what I'm
seeing this I just I don't know if I'll
remember what I'm seeing I just know
that in the media in the now in the
present I am suffering it's like a Zen
riddle of pain it's like which is worse
the sort of thing you remember more or
the sort of thing that you have to
suffer through in the immediate and the
suffering just seems much more worse
right now but hopefully I'll just forget
about it
was that an eagle as a unicorn farting
rainbows thanks so probably the first
creative thing I've seen in this how
many dance numbers can they have in this
film Christ so we finally get something
that looks like the game only like an
hour and 10 minutes why do I feel like
nothing will get better because of
No is it still too late to review showed
us have you ever stolen anyone's
children I mean you look like you would
creepy moments in this film yeah I need
some angry blocking birds bet the name
of the movie it's a little strange how
much this movie wants to say the word
like okay we had to make this piece
of we really want to say and
it's a snap staircase who thinks of that
it's fascinatingly not funny smell
staircase who thinks of that like what
how is that supposed to be funny just
explain it to me he's gotta have the
eggs with him in the castle what the
heck's a cast that's where we're going
why is that funny
I enjoy time really it's like sometimes
it's like I get where a joke is coming
from it just doesn't work these I just
don't even get literally and I think a
five-year-old could write a better
script because of fibro at least we have
more random non sequiturs yeah
oh no I get it it's just one giant
rickroll you thought you were gonna
watch a movie but no just cramped you
know we always make a joke of you know
how did a movie get this high rating
even though it's a low rating but how
did this get 43%
he's got 43% yeah
43% critic City about what I'm ashamed
to call myself a critic this our kind
has betrayed us never mind do you see
this that happened if we all let it
happen much longer is this going to tank
oh this is this is like being on a
holiday weekend at the grocery store in
the world's longest line waiting for the
cashier and you've got kids acting like
brats in front of you in the grocery
basket and kids acting like brats behind
you and you're just stuck there and the
lines not moving and then I could
throwing candy bars and and
[Music]
everyone's
in fact at some point the line moves
backwards no how is that possible and
the parents and relatives
yeah they reward the kids really
terrible and then in the mean time an
express lane opens wreden she put the 20
other people go before you can even get
there and you still haven't moved an
inch
that is this movie yeah I think that's
fair stop please just stop chill for a
second just take a breath of
intelligence now breathe in so great
take a single breath cuz I want this
over as soon as possible
oh my god no
boiled horrific ly alive listen oh my
god that'd be amazing do it because you
know they'd still do it wrong they do it
in a way that wouldn't be entertaining
this is dynamite I'm running on fumes
this is tough I mean I really feel
Dumber watching my teaching job cuz he's
a bad how drunk do you think Peter
Dinklage was reading these alliances I
think the real question is who was sober
reading these life I love oh this is the
Angry Birds movie at the end just to
remind you in case you want to know what
you're venting your rap at it's the
Angry Birds movie ah now wait a minute
there's a dance sequence at the end of
this you don't say three people wrote
the story because it's like yeah Birds
oh I don't want to do this okay
there's pigs I don't want to do
this and so it was like the game and
that was it then they gave it to a
shitty scream like just a slap to my
brain that was just oh there's gotta be
like there's gotta be a few laughs yeah
there has to be house more than two or
three there's gotta be like five or six
little chuckles but it's like no so
excuse for this
there's no excuse we have failed as a
species it's over bring the asteroid I
welcome it well thank you angry birther
make us realise but oh I got
nothing left nothing left right where's
your bourbon
to change it all
you